the 570 days of masks social distancing
bankrupt businesses canceled holidays
and injection mandates have been bad
i do not mean to downplay them in the
united states the public health
dictatorship
has been onerous but
relative to some other parts of the
world
we've actually gotten off easy if you
want to know how far the libs are
willing to take these lock down measures
just take a look at australia where one
state in australia is pairing mandatory
selfies with facial recognition software
to make sure you never leave your home
today the call has gone out to everyone
in home quarantine in victoria to take
part of our our pilot program and what
that means is that they will receive
random phone calls and they have to
answer uh within five minutes with a
selfie sent to this app which will then
geo track uh where that person is and to
make sure that they are who they say
they are as well if they don't answer
within that five minute period that's
when health officers come knocking
i did not believe that was a real clip
when i saw it i actually had to look it
up to find the news story to see that
that's that is real
victoria in australia is actually doing
this they obviously want to spread it
out much wider than just this test
program
once a penal colony
always a penal colony and it's not just
australia just this week dr fauci and
the cdc have made clear that the only
thing preventing these sorts of measures
here at home in the united states is the
sheer intransigence of the american
people they just can't get away with it
but make no mistake
if the ruling class could it would and
it still might i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from johnny nalas who
says you know fauci is lying when he
starts his answer with absolutely not
this is true this is one of fouchy's
tells when fauci is caught in a lie you
see this especially when rand paul is
grilling him on capitol hill when he
gets caught dead to rights in a lie
fauci's tell is not to waffle a little
bit it's not even to hedge it's to
double down senator poole you are
absolutely incorrect and when he says
that you know that rand paul or whoever
is interrogating him has totally got
fouchy's number now when you want to be
able to hear things really clearly hear
hear between all the noise make sure you
really hear what's going on
i would recommend you check out raycon's
man do i miss my raikon earbuds i do i
miss them so much it's not it's not that
i lost them they've got a really cool
case and actually they've got cool
colors so it's not it's not easy to lose
them
it's not that i it's not that they broke
certainly they're really high quality
it's that my
wife stole them she took them she tried
them out they sounded great and now
they're hers the everyday earbuds from
raycon they look they feel they sound
better than ever you get three new sound
profiles to make sure everything you're
listening to sounds it's best with just
the right amount of bass there's an all
new awareness mode for when you need to
listen to your surroundings instead
eight hours of play time 32 hours of
battery life built-in mic so you can
take calls on the earbuds at the press
of a button and they start at half the
price of the other premium audio brands
they sound just as good they're really
phenomenal they've got a 45 day
happiness guarantee
you're going to love them right now my
listeners can get 15 off their raycon
order at buyracon.com knowles that's
byracon.com knowles to save 15 percent
on raycons that is by raycon
dot com slash k-n-o-w l-e-s
i
didn't believe it i should have believed
it
with regard to this this australia story
obviously australia has been sort of
leading the way in in these onerous
lockdown measures but i just couldn't
believe you're telling me that some
government flack or one of his proxies
is going to call you up say okay right
now send me a selfie and you've got to
send a selfie and then they're going to
use geo tracking and facial recognition
to make sure that you're not leaving
your home and if not they're going to
send the police to your door kick your
door in and tell you hey you've got to
be home where are you senator search
party and yet
we already have this technology i
remember i was coming back from france i
was in france a couple of months ago
it was actually right before i flew back
in the day that all the really crazy
lockdown measures went into place and i
was just flying in and i went through
the
global entry checkpoint if you have a if
you have a card you sign up it's like
100 bucks you get a card and it makes it
easier to go through customs so i go
through and you used to have to scan
your passport and then you'd enter your
information now you just walk right by
you look at the machine and it prints
out all of your information it's very
very spooky how does it work it's facial
recognition this is being used by
private businesses it's being used by
your iphone it's being used by tech
companies and it's also being used by
the government and do you think that the
government in cahoots very often with
big tech with these huge asymmetries of
power do you think they're only going to
use that power for good or do you think
maybe they're going to use that power to
deprive you of some of your traditional
rights and liberties
and way of life do you think you think
it's only in australia you don't think
fouchy would do this the second he could
you don't think the cdc would do this
you don't think the fda would do this we
know that they would they're already
trying these things
they're already testing the waters of
the permanent public health state there
was a headline just on monday
comes out from sinclair broadcasting
headline cdc recommends virtual
thanksgiving this year i did a double
take because i remember last year the
cdc said we had to do a virtual
thanksgiving that was uh just a few
months after 15 days to slow this bread
now we're
570 days since
15 days to slow this bread
we're still not allowed to celebrate
thanksgiving
no no we're not cdc wants you to stay
away from your family not travel not
gather together not acknowledge the
holiday in a in a traditional way until
there was an update here was the update
uh uh october 5th
update so it was just one day later the
centers for disease control and
prevention removed their 2021 holiday
guidance tuesday and said the update was
a mishap the agency said its
recommendations for future gatherings
that mirrored 2020 guidance does not
reflect this year's and new suggestions
are coming soon
what changed what changed
the cdc said yep just like last year
you're gonna have to lock down and have
a virtual thanksgiving and then they
said oh actually jk
nope psych never mind
what changed did the science change wow
there must have been some real
scientific discoveries between monday
and tuesday is that no what happened was
the people
derided them mocked them pushed back
protested
rent their garments and gnashed their
teeth and the cd said okay actually
never mind never was what dr fauci said
over the weekend dr fauci was one on one
of the sunday shows and they said hey
can we have christmas this year or is it
too soon to tell he goes you know it's
really too soon to tell
you no you might not be able to get
christmas this year
and then there was pushback and he goes
i never said you couldn't have christmas
yes you did you did you said it's too
soon to tell meaning
there's a good chance that we don't have
christmas then the pushback happened and
then you said no of course you can have
christmas never mind
what changed was not the science what
changed was
the politics
and this is frankly good news for us
because
i know that some people are still
believing the ridiculous narrative that
the government is putting out that this
is all based on the science or whatever
but it's not it's not at all based on
the science whatever the science is it's
based on the political whims of our
leaders and
the bureaucrats that they have put in
charge and so
the good news about that is well we
might not be able to change the laws of
physics we might not be able to change
the chemistry of virus although dr fauci
did a pretty good job changing the
chemistry of a virus by funding gain and
function research that's another subject
what we can do is change the political
situation we can make it such that
these people cannot get away with it one
way to do it which i've been
recommending from
if not day one of the lockdowns at least
day two
is just ignore these people live your
lives
pay no heed to the fouchies of the world
and the bureaucrats and the busybodies
who tell you to muzzle up all the time
and who tell you to get 17 000
injections and to tell you not to have
christmas and tell you not to get
married or go to your funerals not your
funeral i hope to go to the other family
gatherings and religious rituals just go
just ignore them just go live your life
don't give them power that they do not
that they do not yet
at least possess
speaking of the holiday season it might
be a leaner holiday season for people
not just thanksgiving but i'm looking
looking ahead to christmas
the reason it might be a little bit
leaner is that a very important
inflation measure has reached its
highest level since 1991
1991 that was just about 20 years after
joe biden first entered the u.s senate
1991 now we're approaching 50 years
since he entered national politics
according to the bureau of economic
analysis
personal consumption spending
so spending on your personal consumption
rose by 130.5
billion dollars in august so this is a
4.3 year-over-year hike in the personal
consumption expenditures price index
stick with me here for a second
also in august personal income rose
so that the the consumption spending
rose over 130 billion dollars
personal income rose 35 and a half
billion dollars
so there's about a 95 billion dollar gap
here
personal consumption spending increased
95 billion dollars more than income
increased and by the way
the the only reason that income
increased that much is because of the
government
subsidies because the government was
just doling out money to try to keep
people going which is one of one of the
things that is leading to this inflation
disposable income only rose 18.9 billion
dollars
so
because the the consumption spending is
vastly outpacing the
income growth
or the growth of consumption spending is
vastly outpacing the income growth
purchasing power is diminishing your
dollar is going
much
less far than it used to go and this is
really really bad news you are getting
poorer because of the biden
administration's stupid policies
that is happening in real time okay and
it reminds us of an eternal political
truth that the left always ignores and
that the right sometimes ignores as well
namely
eventually the bill comes due
eventually the bill comes due what
you're hearing from aoc right now
notably but lots of democrats is we can
spend a zillion dollars and we can give
people freebies all the time and we can
shut down the economy and not work for a
year or more than a year and it's going
to be fine it's not going to cost you
anything actually
that that situation has never existed
that has never existed anywhere in the
world people who are promising you that
are promising you something that never
was and never will be
eventually the bill is going to come due
if you if you shut down huge segments of
the economy for a year
we're going to be less prosperous we're
going to be less wealthy if you just
print up a bunch of money and just give
away a bunch of money the money is going
to be less valuable
okay and that there is no magic wand
that joe biden or anyone else can wave
to change that situation now if you do
want a really magical solution to
protect your family and your home i
recommend you check out ring i've got
some pretty valuable stuff in my home
i'm not talking about furniture or
i don't know jewelry or i actually don't
have a lot of valuable stuff with regard
to that
i do have valuable
wife and baby okay and i want to make
sure that they are safe
i love ring alarm i love it
if i am in my home if i am in the office
if i am on a beach on the other side of
the world if i'm on the road i do have
to travel a fair bit for work i can be
totally safe and secure that my wife and
my cute little baby will know who is
outside the door before they open that
door and anyone actually can keep an eye
on any any inch of their house inside
outside with ring alarm it's super easy
you can control it from your phone
protect your home anytime from anywhere
with ring alarm so simple to install
even i can do it i'm not the handiest
guy in the world okay it'll just give
you peace of mind and the price is
extraordinarily low go to ring.com
knowles for a special offer on a ring
alarm security kit today build a system
that is right for your home have it up
and running in minutes ring dot com
slash knowles that is ring.com
knowles
huge problems on the economy right now
especially with regard to inflation huge
problems on foreign policy you saw the
collapse of afghanistan uh a
weakness on the part of the united
states on the world stage or enemies
aggressing you're seeing a huge crisis
at the southern border
the the immigration issue
thousands and thousands many many
thousands of illegal aliens pouring
across the border well over 1.2 1.3
million illegal aliens already in the
country this year who are now harassing
u.s senators in the bathroom
really bad stuff mr president what is
your answer to all of these crises that
are going on on your watch
parenthetically when you build a
charging station it's like back in the
day when my grandpop worked for the
american oil company back in the
tournament in the
1920 in that area they went from state
to state convincing people that they put
allow them to put 20 000 gallons of
gasoline under the ground they didn't
want them around
thank you for clearing that up mr
president i
i now am somehow more confused than i
was before you started speaking
we play these every so often on the show
i guess more than every so often on the
show these clips of joe biden just
rambling incoherently often not even
speaking real english words just sort of
slurring words making up words and then
even if you can make out the words
talking about things that are just
completely out of left field and my
grandpapa said when you see when you go
to the pool with the hairy legs and the
corn pop says well hey chocolate
chocolate chip chocolate chocolate chip
come on jack
we i play those on the show
not
to make fun of joe biden for being a bit
senile he's obviously on the decline but
happens to everyone it'll happen it'll
happen to you too someday and not just
to make fun of him for for being
not the brightest bulb in the pack
that's not a function of age that's
always been true joe biden has always
been at the lower end of the iq spectrum
in washington dc which is really saying
something
but i
i mention it because it shows you that
there is not a lucid person at the helm
of the united states government right
now
right the person who is supposed to be
in charge joe biden
does not really know what's going on
okay i'm not saying he's a complete
vegetable and they just you know put him
in his room and he watches matlock all
day they may do that but but i'm not
even saying that i'm sure he goes to
meetings and
does some things but he does not have
his finger on the pulse of what is going
on in the government
and so other people are taking advantage
and in some cases the ball is just being
dropped
and so even in the crises that are not
manufactured for democrat political
advantage they're just happening because
no one is really running the show you
don't need to take my word for it
i'm not just making some hack partisan
argument because i don't like biden and
so i'm i'm saying that he's just a you
know completely incompetent leader talk
to john kerry so john kerry works for
joe biden was a colleague of joe biden
for many years in the united states
senate john kerry former secretary of
state now he's the climate czar
for joe biden and so john kerry has
always had this this very close
relationship with the french he which of
course just makes perfect sense and the
the french right now are very upset with
the united states because we've formed a
partnership with the united kingdom and
with australia to help
uh stop the rise of china and france was
very upset by this and they pulled their
diplomats out of the united states and
they made a big show and john kerry was
explaining how this went down and made
clear to an interviewer he was not
attacking joe biden he actually thought
he was sort of defending joe biden i
think
john kerry made clear that
not only did joe biden
not handle the situation correctly
he didn't even know what the situation
was
president biden asked me about it and i
told him and expressed
you told joe biden that it was not the
right he asked me he said what's the
situation and i explained exactly
he wasn't he had not been aware of that
he literally literally had not been
aware of what had transpired and i don't
want to go into the details of it but
suffice it to say
that
that the president uh
my president is very committed to
strengthening the relationship and
making sure that this is a small event
of the past and moving on to the much
more important future
that is such a sad clarification john
kerry had to make there because it's
it's not you know headline john kerry
destroys joe biden he's not he thinks
he's defending joe biden here
because the question is how did this
happen why did the united states diss
france in this way and allow france a
decent ally to
you know now pull their diplomats and
now there's all this rancor between the
two nations he said well you know look
look look here puppet look monkey i told
president biden that
and the reporter asked for a
clarification goes you told him that you
did not think it was a good idea to oh
no i mean i literally just told him that
like he didn't know what was happening
so i just told him what was happening i
said yes there's a country called france
they speak with a funny accent and they
eat snails and they are very upset with
us now joe why are they upset john well
because and he had to just explain the
nuts and bolts of what had happened
forget about what the right course of
action was forget about what had led to
that moment he had to explain that
to the president why is that john
kerry's job
the climate czar
it's not it's not even as though john
gary is the secretary of state name who
hasn't been the secretary of state in a
long time
it's because the president
has no idea
what is going on he is completely
checked out and you are seeing this
reflected in our national policy so
notably at the southern border
they're border patrol agents trying to
do their job trying to stop the flow of
illegal aliens pouring across the border
they
when they are allowed to do their jobs
they do a pretty good job of it
when they have their hands tied behind
their backs then the illegal aliens just
just pour over now they're not even
allowed to ride horses so they're not
even allowed to police certain areas of
the border anymore
the border patrol agents
just finally caught up with a guy
who was sneaking across the border
illegally
who had previously been deported
for murder
so
this was in the the rio grande valley
sector border patrol these agents arrest
an illegal alien who had been convicted
by a florida court for homicide
so
i guess it could have been manslaughter
too either way i don't really want this
guy in the country the convicted killer
re-entered the united states with a
group of five other migrants they
finally caught up with this guy and you
know there there's some percentage of
the illegal aliens that they do catch up
with there's a far greater percentage
that they don't who just get released
into the country and that's that
but this guy one of the migrants a
honduran national has a conviction from
a miami court for homicide how many more
of these guys are coming into the
country
how
how many
they're just trying to be liberated
they're just coming from latin america
to be liberated speaking of
liberation movements from latin america
there's a clip going around right now
of ibram kendy he's sort of the
mack daddy of anti-racism this this new
ideology that's very influenced by
critical race theory and other
radical leftist movements from the 20th
century so kendy was speaking at a
church i put that in quotes i'm not sure
the exact nature of this church doesn't
sound very christian to me
and kindy
explained the religious underpinnings of
his ideology
liberation theology in other words jesus
was a revolutionary
and the job of the christian
is to revolutionize society
that the job of the christian is to
liberate society
from
the powers on on earth that are
oppressing humanity
everybody understand that so
that's liberation theology in a nutshell
save your theology
a different type of theology the job of
the christian
is to go out
and save
these individuals who are behaviorally
deficient
in other words we're to bring them into
the church
these individuals
who
are doing all of these evil sinful
things and heal them
and save them
and then once we've saved them
we've done our jobs
and and to me anti-racists
fundamentally reject
savior theology
this is a very telling clip this is a
very important clip for understanding
the anti-racist movement
so from the beginning you can tell that
ibram kennedy though he seems to be
talking about christianity is not you
can tell this from the very first
sentence when ibram kennedy says
jesus was a revolutionary as a general
rule
if
someone is referring to jesus
exclusively in the past tense
there's a very good chance you're not
dealing with a christian
because christians believe that christ
was crucified he died and rose again
from the dead and the lives my redeemer
lives this is something
we say very often this is central to our
understanding of the world
if you do not i mean christ himself says
this before abraham was i am that he is
essen the the being himself
right i am i am that i am is what god
says his name is when he's speaking to
moses
so from the very beginning we can see
ibrahim kennedy whatever he's talking
about it's not really christianity but
this difference between liberation
and savior theology and his words this
is the difference between christianity
and this radical sort of
leftism
now when you want to uh make sure
that your
future is protected your financial
future is protected i mean even among
all this these crazy times i would
strongly recommend you check out alto
ira cryptocurrency is soaring in
popularity
everyone is getting involved we did an
interview on this show with a big crypto
guy not too long ago
very often when people are beginning to
invest in crypto they're doing so in how
do i put this not the most advantageous
way okay well here's how you get smart
about it with an alto crypto ira you can
trade crypto like bitcoin and avoid or
defer the taxes you can get into
investing in crypto and do it in a tax
advantaged retirement account altos
crypto ira is the easy way to get crypto
into an ira trade all you want without
the tax headache create an account in
just a few minutes invest with as little
as 10 bucks no setup charges secure
trading 24 7 through alto's integration
with coinbase 80 plus coins available
including bitcoin ethereum and cordano
you want to swap some sushi swap with
your bitcoin okay that's cool no problem
alto has you covered you i don't think
you can order sushi with with uh alto
but but you can trade it's very very
helpful open an alto crypto ira right
now with as little as 10 bucks go to
altoira dot com slash michael
m-i-c-h-a-e-l-a-l-t-o-i
michael you cannot get raw fish but you
can get a great way to invest in these
coins altoira dot com slash michael go
check out alto ira today also check out
ben's show the leftist quest to seize
control of facebook they'll be talking
about what's going on with the facebook
quote unquote whistleblower
and you also have to subscribe and start
listening to morning wire on apple
spotify or wherever you listen to
podcasts leave a five star review if you
like what you hear we'll be right back
with a lot more
ibrahim kendi who is presently the head
honcho of anti-racism the capo de
tuticapi of race hustlers ibrahim kendi
is
has this viral video that was going
around of him speaking in some sort of
church or some sort of building and
congregation that referred to itself as
a church about liberation theology and
he says liberation theology holds that
the purpose of christianity and of the
christian in the world is to liberate
everybody from the bonds of oppression
and tradition and whatever else
he says this
contrasts with savior theology which
holds that the the role of the christian
in the world is to go evangelize and
spread the gospel and bring people into
the body of christ so what ibrahim
kennedy is derisively referring to as
savior theology is also just known as
christianity that christianity which is
the point is to spread the good news
just as the apostles did just as
the disciples of jesus did go out and
spread the good news of the gospel bring
people into the body of christ and save
them ibrahim kennedy says this is very
bad we cannot go out and save people if
you go out there and you say people are
doing bad things and they need to stop
doing bad things and start doing good
things and accept jesus and and come
into the church that's very bad that's
oppressive
that that reeks of white supremacy or
whatever
so we can't have any of that instead we
need to liberate people
and that the key here is this word
liberation
because to my mind to my mind as a as a
catholic as a christian
in the broadest sense
the two are the same thing the two are
the same thing
when you
come to faith
when you accept
jesus when you accept
theological religious truth
you are freed you are freed from the
bonds of sin
and what does it mean to be freed of the
bonds of sin well you see it in the
gospels jesus says the man who sins is a
slave to sin
take the religious stuff
away for a moment just focus in this
very practical tangible way we all know
that when we sin when we pick up bad
habits
we become slaves to those sins we call
this addiction
when you do too many drugs all of a
sudden you can't control whether or not
you do the drugs your your lower will
runs away with you your appetite runs
away with you you can't do it this is
true even with food if you if you
overeat you can't put down that cupcake
you can't say no you don't have
self-control the point of liberal
education
which we mentioned on the show a lot is
to make sense of your freedom tamp down
those base appetites cultivate the
higher rational will which mediates
between the appetite and the divine will
okay that's the that's the two second
summary of what we mean by this
what
ibram candy believes is that true
liberation is being able to do whatever
you want
i think it even goes further true
liberation is the freedom to commit vice
and sin and to pursue your appetites and
that is
slavery that is
that is a christianity without a without
christ that is christianity without god
because you you can do it all yourself
as long as as long as we the liber the
liberators come in
and we free you from the bonds of
tradition as long as the anti-racists go
in and free you from the bonds of
whatever oppressive social structures
there are then you can be free to do
whatever you want and you don't need god
and you don't need christ and you don't
need grace and you don't need a religion
it is
a god without wrath leading a people
without sin into a kingdom without
judgment through the ministrations of a
christ without a cross
so that you can do you and do whatever
you want it's the opposite of
christianity but it adopts the language
of christianity
and this
it's important to know where this
ideology comes from because it's
pervading all the military now the
schools the our workplaces
but it comes down to that same old
problem that we've been talking about
the problem of liber what do we mean by
liberty is liberty just the ability to
do whatever you want or is it the right
to do what you ought to do
a related point from jennifer aniston
you know that other great philosopher
jennifer aniston
rachel from friends jennifer aniston
just posted
a series of stories to her instagram
talking about how upset she is that
babies in texas won't be killed quite as
often anymore she hates the pro-life
laws she supports
the
uh
abortion industry and she posted a clip
of herself from that absolutely
insufferable show friends and she
she she writes in it i repeat
no uterus
no opinion
so if you're not a woman
you have no right to have an opinion
about abortion
i mention it look jennifer aniston is
not i don't think she's the leading mind
on public matters in this country but a
lot of people say this and we talk about
a lot of other stupid slogans in the
pro-abortion movement this one
may be the stupidest
one now it's becoming outdated i think
jennifer aniston is revealing
how unhip she is because of course we're
now told that
non-women can become pregnant men can
become pregnant non-binary you know all
sorts of made-up sexes and genders they
can become pregnant too so that
distinction no longer exists
but but also that even the principle
that
unless you
can
perform a certain action you should have
no
you should have no say in that action as
a matter of public policy we don't apply
that to any other aspect of society
right we don't say well and unless you
have tumors you can't make cancer policy
no tumor no
opinion
we don't say well unless you
have murdered someone you do not have
the right to craft laws about murder
well unless you this unless you that
unless you this unless you that no of
course not
we wouldn't do
we wouldn't we wouldn't tolerate that
because
politics refers to the public refers to
public matters not just personal matters
public matters as well
to say nothing of the fact that abortion
involves another person not just you and
not just the mother but also the baby
right so
they repeat these slogans on the left
because they don't have arguments to
make but a lot of people confuse cheap
slogans with arguments and it's
important every so often to remind
ourselves that these things that we hear
that's my body my choice reproductive
rights no uterus no opinion blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah that
we can
become
i don't know
asleep we can become unconscious of just
how stupid these arguments are and and
the reason it matters that jennifer
aniston said it is because that show had
such cultural influence i i actually
enjoyed the show when it was on the air
i recently went back and tried to watch
it it's unwatchable it's so terri it's
so trite it is so
wrong like every decision these people
make is just wrong and bad for them and
it's not all that funny even and it's
just so
shallow and in a way in a way it's
actually quite radical but that's how
the the establishment pushes their
agenda
okay very important to see through these
things it's very very difficult you know
in a world where where the entire
establishment is pushing these shallow
messages what we're hearing from the
elected representatives now on the left
is don't pay attention to those details
don't pay attention to those facts aoc
just goes on one of the sunday shows she
says look when you're talking about the
big budget bill
don't focus on the numbers president
biden according to our reporting from ed
o'keefe our correspondent says you're
gonna have to settle for about two
trillion dollars is that an acceptable
ceiling for you
so here's the here's where i think the
problem is is that when we talk about
top line numbers
there's a lot that is is hidden in that
discussion and so
the reason why this this conversation
shouldn't be about numbers but it should
be about what substantive programs are
are willing to be excluded or that's
coming from the white house yeah but the
the white house isn't making the demands
to exclude universal child care or
universal pre-k this is coming for the
more conservative wing of the democratic
party and those are but those are the
conversations that we need to have
when you're talking about the budget you
shouldn't talk about numbers that's what
aoc says
and you know what oh i hate to say it i
i hate to say it she's right
she's right
i mean she's not right
if you're an accountant
she's not right if you care about the
health of the national economy
but she is right as a political matter
what she's saying is
yeah these democrats say three and a
half trillion dollars is too much money
you only want two trillion dollars okay
what program do you want to cut
oh you want to cut universal pre-k first
of all i don't think pre-k should even
exit i didn't go to pre-k did you go to
pre-k i did not go to pre-k
i i made it out just fine i learned my
letters and numbers just fine without
pre-k now now i actually have friends i
kid you not who say they're sending
their kids to school at age two
because yes they don't they don't want
to say that they're sending the kid to
daycare
so it has to be really fancy so they say
i'm sending my my child to school
you're a child who
can't speak and who drools all day
they're going to school what are they
they're going to work on uh you know
differential equations or something no i
don't think so
but the the reason for this is that the
reason as a political matter that the
left pushes
pre-k and pre-pre-k and post-high school
and post-college and everyone needs to
get a phd in gender studies is so that
the influence of the family on the
individual will be diminished and the
influence of the state will be increased
and this is not some crazy conspiracy
theory i mean this has been in the
discussion of political philosophy going
back to plato at least and the the left
is pretty open about this that they do
not want these families with their
peculiar traditions and their bible
thumping to to form
children they believe that it's the
state's role to form these children and
so they push for these things and the
the reason that parents are tempted to
do it is because it's a tough economy
out there and you can't really survive
most people cannot really survive on one
income and so both parents have to work
so you got to pay someone to watch your
kid you've got a
the wife has to go work for some guy so
that she can make money so that the guy
can pay some other so that the husband
can go pay some other woman to go raise
the kid and it's a very convoluted
system but
as a result a lot of people are going to
say hold on you better not cut my pre-k
hold on you better not cut
whatever goody program i want in the
budget and that's how
you get to preserve the three and a half
trillion dollar budget
it's because no one wants to cut the
specific programs it's a political
matter aoc is absolutely right and i
wish republicans would learn from her
nancy pelosi said the same thing the
other day she said let's not talk about
numbers let's talk about values yeah hey
republicans take notes
get your get your pen out and take notes
stop just talking about well actually
you know but that's the gdp well blah
blah blah who cares who cares what do
you want to do with the money what do
you want to do with the government why
should we vote for you what are you
going to do with it what are you going
to do with the power the left is giving
us a vision it's a bad vision
what are you giving us well what we're
going to do is we're going to outsource
even more jobs so the gdp takes up
another 20
oh oh cool bro great i can't i'm
definitely going to vote for you then
that makes a lot of sense
speaking of wealthy americans
most wealthy americans find themselves
in a conundrum right now and it's a
conundrum that we actually talked about
with respect to aoc yesterday the
conundrum is this they've got a lot of
money but they don't trust their lazy
kids not to squander their money
and ruin their own lives in the process
there's a survey that just came out
from the motley fool
that shows it was a survey of 2000
american adults with net worths over one
million dollars
and a little over three quarters of
these individuals plan to leave
inheritances
and
almost as many 76 say they're going to
leave inheritances
and i guess a quarter of them are just
going to go on a spending spree before
they die and 68
of of those millionaires
plan to have that money accessible
only after their heirs meet certain
conditions
so the vast majority of these people
and so the vast vast majority of people
who are leaving inheritances
say they're not just going to leave
their kids the money
kevin o'leary from shark tank
quote designed a trust that skips his
adult children and will support his
grandchildren until they graduate from
college and this is a design that over
60 percent of people who were surveyed
by this
outlet the motley fool
said that they were considering doing
why is that
why
is the reason just that they
they have some vendetta against their
kids or they the kids aren't good enough
for them or they think the kids aren't
going to use the money as well as the
grandchildren are
no it's not just that
it's that they don't want the money to
ruin the kids lives they don't want the
kids to just become lazy and degenerate
and give in to libertinism and just
basically drink or
shoot up or squander all of that money
and ruin their lives in the process
we were talking about this yesterday
with regard to aoc's proposal for a
four-day work week
so people should have a four-day work
week
and they should have three days off and
oh could you imagine all the things you
would do with your three days off oh my
gosh you would become an artist or a
painter or a poet or whatever and that's
what everyone says nancy pelosi made the
same claim many years ago with regard to
the the obamacare debate
and the reality is for most people
for almost everybody you won't do that
you'll just sit on the couch
and some people think that oh gosh if
only i could retire oh i wish i could
retire at age 35 you know and then oh
man i'd sit on a beach somewhere i'd be
so happy no you wouldn't you'd be
miserable because you were made to work
i'm not saying you've got to work at the
widget factory or in the coal mine all
day there are other kinds of work you
can work
on your family building up your family
you can work on actually cultivating a
hobby but it's not just you know sitting
with a glass of chablis painting
something painting is hard work writing
poetry is hard work all these things
that we consider to be very simple
recreational activities if you want to
do them well and you want them to
actually do something for you then
they're going to require a lot of work
okay and what these millionaires are
they're they're
acknowledging this even if it's not
consciously it's subconsciously
we are made to do things to be
productive and in a society that is told
not just stay home whether it's stay
home because of the lockdowns or stay
home with the universal basic income or
just go away we're going to pay you off
to go away with welfare benefits or
whatever that is an in human society
that is not only is that not good for
the society as a whole it's it's really
bad even for the individuals that it is
purportedly going to help
just laziness mankind is not meant to be
lazy
speaking of children
speaking of of children
won't somebody please think of the
children
a woman has come forward
at facebook she used to work at facebook
then she left facebook
and now she is a whistleblower
she is a whis she's
speaking truth to power
yes that's right and she's speaking
truth to power so clearly that everyone
in the ruling class loves her and is
giving her lots of plaudits
that's weird that's a strange that's a
strange fact
the woman is uh coming forward she was a
former facebook product manager her name
is frances hogan she is saying that
facebook has
she's making two claims facebook is
not good for kids and when kids use
facebook and instagram too much it's not
good for their mental health and also
facebook is not censoring conservatives
enough and that's a bad thing and one of
the reasons she quit facebook is because
they they were not willing to interfere
even more in the political process and
suppress conservatives even more than
they already are so those are the two
angles here and as a result of her
heroic whistleblowing
uh senators on capitol hill and the
mainstream media and everyone else are
giving her a big round of applause
my name is frances haugen
i used to work at facebook
i joined facebook because i think
facebook has the potential to bring out
the best in us
but i'm here today because i believe
facebook's products harm children
stoke division and weaken our democracy
the company's leadership knows how to
make facebook and instagram safer but
won't make the necessary changes because
they have put their astronomical profits
before people
congressional action is needed
they won't solve this crisis without
your help
yesterday we saw facebook get taken off
the internet
i don't know why i went down but i know
that for more than five hours facebook
wasn't used to deepen divides
destabilize democracies and make young
girls and women feel bad about their
bodies we can have social media we enjoy
that connects us without tearing our
democracy apart our democracy putting
our children in danger and sowing ethnic
violence around the world
we can do better
now this is confusing because she keeps
using these these two lines in the same
breath it's harming girls it's really
bad for children okay well yeah okay i
guess we could all agree with that maybe
there's some regulation there and it's
harming our democracy
well hold on that seems like a totally
separate issue what do you mean harm
harming our democracy oh you mean
because
conservatives while they are censored on
facebook are not censored quite as much
on facebook as they are on other
platforms and therefore conservatives do
well on facebook and actually do you
know who she's talking about she's
talking about us
she's talking about us right here at the
michael knowles show and the daily wire
because we are the top publishers on
facebook and we have been for a very
long time we have formed our business in
many ways to be able to compete at a
very serious level in the new media
we're not an old media company we're not
an old tv company or an old newspaper
company so we were able to be agile and
focus our business and tailor it to
those specifications for new media and
so we're the top publisher on facebook
now the left still dominates facebook
because yes there's the daily wire yes
there's the blaze yes there are a
handful of conservative outlets out
there but the vast majority of them are
left-wing outlets so while yes the daily
wire punches above our weight absolutely
when you consider the right wing outlets
compared to the left wing out let's the
left wing out let's totally dominate but
that's not good enough for this woman
and so she says no you've got to
suppress the conservatives
and in order to make that argument more
palatable she is she is couching it
in
in protecting children but those two
issues have nothing to do with one
another they're just going after
facebook because facebook is the fairest
and they're not even particularly fair
but they're the fairest to conservatives
all right the way that you know that
this woman is not a whistleblower that
she is not speaking truth to power is
that the most powerful people in the
company or in the country rather are
promoting her
the entire ruling class
i guess with the exception of facebook
which is one of the big tech companies
but it's in this case it's sort of the
odd man out other than that all of the
institutions in our country with power
are promoting this woman
because she is not speaking truth to
power she is the power and they are all
turning on facebook which is another
power because in this case facebook is
not going along entirely with the agenda
and completely shutting up conservatives
in the way that google and youtube and
twitter are
moving
and so they're giving facebook a warning
they're giving facebook a slap on the
wrist
and this is an important lesson to
remember
we love this idea of speaking truth to
power and yeah you know this is a very
romantic notion my friend spencer clavin
just did a whole episode on this uh as
as it pertained to saint thomas more on
his show young heretics
and we love this idea yes we're going to
speak truth to power
when you are really speaking truth to
power the way that you will know that
you are doing that
is that everyone is going to hate you
and you are going to be derided and
mocked and slandered and persecuted and
very likely killed
okay that's how you'll know that you're
actually speaking truth to power what
we're seeing play out right now on
capitol hill
just like what we were saying play out
with the blm riots and all these other
astroturf social justice movements
is the play-acting version of speaking
truth to power when in fact these people
this quote-unquote whistleblower or the
blm pawns or anyone else what they're
actually doing is upholding the dominant
power structure
that's what we're seeing i think there
are lots of good reasons to reign in
facebook that whistleblower lady isn't
it but what is this about she's talking
about the division within
within facebook well you'll see this
actually happening in new york right now
a statue that was uh involved a bronze
bust of george floyd was defaced on
sunday morning in new york someone threw
some paint at the
at the idol to george floyd the i the
great bronze icon of saint george george
of uh
the blessed fake 20 bills or whatever
so
what is this about why are we defacing
monuments of
george why is there a monument of george
floyd i have no idea why are we defacing
monuments of george floyd
and
why are we defacing monuments of
christopher columbus who's a good man
why are we defacing monuments of george
washington good man of abraham lincoln
good why because we're disagreeing over
what our national symbols are
right that's where a lot of this
division comes from we can't agree the
left wants our symbol to be this guy who
was killed under sad circumstances but
who was also a career criminal who
robbed a pregnant woman at gunpoint who
did a ton of drugs who was committing a
crime well and resisting arrest while he
was killed and so that's sad it's sad
when any man is killed but
very different than you know an innocent
martyr
and
the the right wants our statues to be
george washington christopher columbus
thomas jefferson these great men who
built our civilization
which is it
we will not resolve this rancor in this
division until we can agree on the
shared symbols because the symbols
represent what the country is and right
now we have no idea who we are which is
why people are trying to grab power as
tightly as they can whether they're in
the government they're in big tech
they're in industry to clamp down and
make that decision that decision is
being made right now and we we we need
to fight as hard as we can to keep the
country that we want i'm michael knows
this the michael knoll show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 on
the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show